hello there uh two for Texas Chainsaw
Massacre sorry that sold out weeks ago
which should have been updated on our
website Bernard
but we still have seats for that super
scary Japanese film yes uh pause how
scary how Japanese I think the literal
translation is make Dead with old Faith
baby two two keys come on honey you
promised me a good scare this will be
fun okay
great I'm so scared
don't patronize me you don't think I can
tell when you're faking it oh Phil
so good I know you hated my gum
no excuse me hey uh I'm having a hard
time in there I came to see a movie I'd
already seen knew where all the jump
scares were could you tell me where the
big ones are for this one sorry dude I
haven't seen it
oh God
he's not in the door
something is wrong with you
honey you can't be mad that I wasn't
scared by that movie it was a baby it
had three rows of teeth baby teeth look
it's not your fault it's just sit next
to you I feel like such a wuss just
because you get a little bit squirrely
in a movie doesn't make you wait hang on
why are we crossing the street our house
is right down wait a minute you're not
afraid of the little lady's house are
you you don't know she's little oh we
know she sits up there plotting evil
from her window she's not there she's
always there it stops now we're gonna go
knock on that door introduce ourselves
and put an end to this nuttiness
foreign
[Music]
the envelope Alex dropped off the old
lady never picked it up
what was that oh God Phil what if she
fell we should go check on her yeah I
guess so I am uh right behind you I'm
just gonna go find a flashlight
um
hello
Miss man
hello
[Music]
item a
[Music]
oh
item a
[Music]
Miss man
[Music]
it was Simplicity itself
a year ago Claire accused me for the
millionth time that I couldn't scare her
so I came up with a plan I just sold a
house to a European couple that weren't
going to take possession for a while so
uh last fall item May moved in I told
you she's always up there fortunately
the house was right on Claire's jogging
road so it was easy to introduce Claire
to item a and when I wanted to amp it up
I had item may make contact
then this morning I knew that ax
wouldn't scare Claire I just did that so
she'd accused me of not being able to
scare her it's all about plausibility
damn right it is over the past year Ida
May joined the neighborhood association
hung up a poster for a lost dog signed
up for Meals on Wheels they're not bad
by the way also
she got a lot of knitting done
oh I'm sorry Claire did I scare you
you did this yep how long are you
playing 11 months two weeks and three
days ago I gave birth to item a man
because I had a main man oh don't you
dare do word play film sorry I was
having so much fun what I was wondering
what we were gonna do for the next 30
years of our lives without the kids in
the house and now I know you're getting
twisted I I look at game on
game on what do you mean came on it's
game over nope
buddy this is
can we just travel
[Music]